hahaha
I love yoga so and I love laughing so
I'm really excited to put them together
I like laughing yoga I'm indifferent to
to be frank I have no idea what the
[ __ ] going on here I have no idea
what's gonna happen today I'm sure this
is echoed by my fellow testes but this
is weird I feel like I won't be able to
keep it together for some reason I have
this image in my brain that like we're
all just gonna sit in a circle like
crisscross applesauce namaste I'm a yoga
teacher
that's what Yogi's say right sure yeah
I'm here to introduce you guys to
laughter yoga what is that laughter yoga
is it's just basically getting together
and laughing for no reason
do you like break a sweat no not
necessarily you just break a chuckle
chuckle the first thing I want to teach
you is after everygame we're gonna do
this you're gonna go very good very good
yeah some reason I had in my mind that
we were gonna be doing a lot of
exercises but it was really more just
silly miss so we're gonna go to a
laughter party all right so you're gonna
imagine that you're sleeping in your bed
and imagine you're having a funny dream
and let's go into the shower and you
know you have a laughter shower so when
you turn on the water you have laughter
water had the most infectious laughter
I've ever heard like I feel like part of
why I lost myself was because he had
such a great laugh but I just I lost it
very good
so let's let's go to the party right so
we're gonna go to our car you have one
of these old laughter cards okay so and
it works kind of like a like you know
those long Wars just sort of laughs more
and more something about what was
happening which is so funny he told us
we were gonna meditate and I was kind of
like oh I don't really know if I want to
end this whole thing on like a really
calm meditation and then man and then
from a very deep outside of outer space
imagine a little giggle rocket coming
towards you we say giggle rocket I just
lost my [ __ ] because come on giggle
Rockets hilarious phrase in general I
loved it all I would do this again I
feel like I just got a massage I felt
like I was high the entire time I was
doing that feeling uh pretty pretty
charged it up
okay Drake that was perfect for someone
like me who's giggling like 24/7 anyway
hey being in it and just completely
losing yourself in the process is
something that's hard for me to do to be
honest and today that actually happened
so kudos to the laughter men very good
very good yay he looked a lot like
Stanley Tucci uh handsomer Stanley Tucci
don't show this to Stanley Tucci
oh good jealous it's here
what get it there I got it yeah you get
it it's here